regardez qui nous a rejoint ya des
giulia gad elmaleh qui est avec tout ça
va mon gars tu ça va mal et en veille
d'un marteau ça va question qu'au temps
de te vois frère c'est que c'est l'heure
c'est l'heure à laquelle je fais mon
sport l'aspect pas les faire tenir la
scène michel drucker
j'adore monter les le 'guide' or michel
drucker faire un kiff le vélo mon gars
tu sais je voulais te dire vers toi ou
mon canapé il est rouge pas tu sais quoi
faire je voulais te dire à chaque fois
que tu viens dans l'émission tu sais que
j'y pense trois quatre cinq jours avant
et je lis je sais que je vais faire un
énorme je quitte parce que c'est comme
si tu sais quand tu invites un pote à la
maison le mercredi après midi
et tu sais que tu vas kiffer et ben
voilà bah chaque fois que tu viens c'est
un kif et il ya un extrait toi dans tes
pump et que je voulais revoir
c'était en novembre 2004 c'était sur d8
à l'époque et est en effet jeté puisque
tu avais pris ma place c'est toi qui
présentait l'émission début regardez
c'est gad elmaleh ce ton 2014 regarde
quel bonheur de vous retrouver tous les
soirs bienvenue vous êtes bien sûr des 8
oui dix huit vous êtes sur des 8 entouré
de mes amis de mes camarades les amours
de mes bottés merci d'être là bonsoir
valérie valérie bénaïm est avec nous
dans la vie on va la vie humble avis
elle va magnifique jeu les week-ends
jeudi week-end formidable la toge bat
toujours un petit cadeau un petit
week-end un petit bouquet non j'ai eu un
petit bracelet wpt
il n'a pas osé encore le petit bracelet
quoi un gros revenir s'est pas foulé à
gad elmaleh qui sait tout faire mon
chéri est mon gars de regarder qui nous
a rejoint y habitent le holy il ya des
jours où ça va te remercie d'être là
yahmed s'il a donc à franck gastambide
tient encore la ya une équipe de place
et que l'on vous en parle a tonné
mission là on dirait les gens vous
voient ils font à qui je suis sûr que
les téléspectateurs vous et francky la
télé là on a la clé la voix vous êtes à
la télé gala entre héros bien didier
thomas pesquet écoutez moi le
confinement
ça me fait pas peur j'ai dormi debout
pendant 72
je tire mon frérot je voulais dire un
petit mot sur la mission et sur le début
de l'émission tu sais ces jours ci comme
vous le savez ya plein de gens qui font
des live le partout tu vois il est là
tout le monde et on s'est rendu compte
avec les live qu'on revenait à quelque
chose de très simple c'est à dire même
un peu maladroit sans prod ce qui
comptait c'était l'humour la vanne la
charia d' la connexion est vraiment ce
que j'ai envie de te dire ce soir et
dire au public
sais tu sais ce que tu as réussi à faire
toi antennes et c'est à dire de casser
les codes 2d construire une émission et
quand on y va on n'a pas cette pression
de faire une émission monsieur qu'est ce
qu'il fait en trente ans comme on fait
en ce moment dans les live et je
voudrais juste raconter ces trucs là
c'est que comme moi j'ai commencé à les
l'émission tu voulais préparer beaucoup
tu m'as dit au kebab à tour arrivé tu as
la vo au ni oui ni non à provencher
d'avec sa à présent parce que quand
j'arrivais on vous à cache-cache géante
voix c'est pour ça que je t'aime et
c'est pour ça que j'aime venir dans deux
émissions à les regarder aussi toi bravo
cameroun et c'est génial je t'aime tu es
lo cicero et je te dis aussi pour tout
l'argent une tout l'argent que tu nous
donnes à chaque
[Rires]